it's cobb looking to track what he has
done many times this year including a
couple of starts ago against the oakland
athletics meet grossman at the top
here's the next delivery and this is a
low liner that's caught just above the
shoe tops and it knocks renifo onto his
backside holding on to that one and
that's the game's first out here's scope
at the plate and here's the next pitch
and down there it is chased and missed
and he went after a splitter got him on
strikes that is out number two
well no secret you're going to get a ton
of splits from alex cobb in fact he
throws more change-ups than just about
anybody in the game of baseball so now
two on and we'll see what happens
against the catcher eric haas the
one-two pitch late with the swing and
struck him out boy he was really late on
that swing 29 year old native of the
dominican republic jose uranya
upton pokes a slider just to protect for
the right side it goes long run that's a
fair ball
just protecting a breaking ball away
justin upton with a ground rule double
don't ever leave the top of the order jf
this one it's a slider down and away off
the end of the bat rudder and scoring
position for shohei ohtani the o2
swung on it missed jose pulled the
string but it's the location right that
ball was sinking away from him was a
really good changeup lead off man out in
the second nico two for two with a walk
last night here's the next pitch that's
a shout out to mound stopped by iglesias
whips the second relay to first it's a
double play
boy that was nicely done right there
that ball looked like it might be
trouble when it hit off the back part of
the mound but it
took a bounce and landed right over by
iglesias and the angels turned two on
that one field backed up walsh holding
the bag at first here's the next pitch
it's chopped to walsh and he goes down
to a knee to stop it gets up and just
walks over to the bag it was hit very
close to first the inning is over on the
unassisted put out runner at second
stassey it brings up keon wong
drives that one into center field wong
liked it
hustling on around to stassi he will
score the halo strike first keane wong
good night last night good night tonight
yeah when you're a sinker ball pitcher
you elevate a fastball upstairs it's a
good chance you can make good contact
and get wong did that
picking up his fifth rbi the number
eight hitter is juan legaris
line drive right center field coming
over in a kill but do and then he has to
jump up and make the catch oh man should
be strong and in shape
there goes the runner great great throw
by eric haas
and they nail keon wong trying to steal
the bag release
maybe more importantly right on the
money it's back to the top of the order
grossman
that's a good pitch that's a sinking
fastball that's strike three that's his
best two seamer he's thrown today that's
sinker candelario will be in the batter
here's the delivery texas swing did he
know on the appeal the third base umpire
jeremy riggs brings them up so here's
taylor ward getting ready to bat he's
going to the count
drives that one toward left toward the
corner it goes it's down bounds up
against the wall justin upton here he
comes
butter sends it to the plate the relay
the slide safe at the plate
hanging slider
see that about get that slider into play
got it in there quickly but you see
where it opens that he's just barely at
that base but challenging the throw to
the plate i love the fact because you're
going to force the defense to make a
perfect throw we go to the fourth inning
alex cobb ready to face the veteran
miguel cabrero
struck him out
fastball had some good movement here
three balls and two strikes
tigers got haas from the cleveland
indians and the next delivery swings and
misses that one and
he goes down on a split finger fastball
so back-to-back strikeouts in the
beginning
good room to enter the batter's box
is it four in a row folks
it is
four splitters in a row stayed stubborn
didn't he that's the wipeout one the
non-strike
splitter that's his seventh strikeout in
the game mazara ready to bat took off a
splitter to go to a fastball now
outside corner got the call
eight strikeouts
start the bottom of the fifth inning
here's the 1-1 this ball is hit well
into right center field it's carrying
deep out into right center it is out of
here
lawyer and heapo is swinging the bat
since he's been back with the angels the
two hit night last night his first home
run with the angels this season and the
angels add on it's three nothing so
here's ohtani digging in
drives it to right field toward the wall
what a rocket he went with a fastball
show hey by the way it took about two
seconds running around the faces that
was a rocket he hits out
show hey the money hey denver he's
coming for you home run derby want to
know
that one driven to right field get off
your stopwatch get out your measuring
tape out of here
home run derby here in the bottom of the
fifth that's another two run shot it's
now seven nothing angels
for jared walsh his 16th home run of the
season could be his final batter
regardless
lifted
to right field and it's deep
and it is off the
wall taylor ward misjudged it scoped
trots home cabrera has himself an rbi
double well good for maggie but that was
horrible route efficiency right there
here's the pitch that's a shot in the
left center field that's going to drop
in and roll all the way out to the wall
this is going to score two runs ward
continues to rack up rbis here in this
series against the tigers drives in a
pair more angels lead it 10-1
27 rbis seven doubles
this year for taylor ward
three runs scored
for justin upton tonight
the bottom of the eighth inning oh tony
a one for four tonight
ohtani to the opposite field
magic again
21 home runs it continues to be showtime
tigers are down to their final out
2-2 bouncing ball left side gobbled up
on across the diamond the angel stepped
back strong to 500 behind shohei on
tony's bet and the arm of alex cobb the
angel's victorious 11-3